give me um
what's like your top two or three studio
sessions
ever just just obviously you know
i'm sure racks in the middle has got to
be out there but like in general like
you've had
some insane situation i mean you just
said i told my manager if it ain't jay
kanye or beyonce like i mean obviously
racks
making racks in the middle that whole
process was just fire from the time we
started it till we got it mixed and put
it out like
that [ __ ] was just a moment but um going
back like
when i first met hove that [ __ ] was
crazy what what what session was that
for
that was a watch the throne session and
i had been
you know we was working out of the hotel
in new york mercer hotel yep yep yep so
i have been up there a few days and i'm
like damn all going to come through
i'm just [ __ ] with kanye every day we
making beats together he recording all
my [ __ ] we just cooking
we was working on john legend stuff we
were just literally just cooking
a few days into me being there mind you
it's like a
snow storm and [ __ ] cold as hell so i
walked out
to like walk down the block mind you i'm
freezing to get down there
as soon as i get there i get an email
from yeah like yo you gotta come back to
the studio
so like [ __ ] walk back to the um to
the spot
and i walk in and hove is just you know
what i'm saying sitting right there
and he was just cool as hell like you
know saying i thought i thought like i
had heard like
you know what i'm saying like bro was
like oh some like mean type
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so for um
him to be so cool that [ __ ] was just
flying man like damn like
you know and then we made [ __ ] in
paris it's just like you can't even
[ __ ] write that